Satur Gojo is an absolute monster
activating his domain expansion for just
an instant is enough to knock any human
in the vicinity unconscious and any
longer than 0 seconds and they'll be
robbed of their entire sanity forced to
experience every moment of their life
simultaneously until they finally die as
a result the plant of many of the
villains in Jutsu kaisen like kinjaku
solely hinge on getting Gojo out of the
way because he's just the sole Force
defending the Jitsu worlds and so
honestly it goes to reason that if he
were on the other side here Jitsu High
wouldn't even stand a chance against
their star teacher after all he is a
special great sorcerer and a special
grade is a sorcerer with such unlimited
potential that the limits of their power
are just purely measureless for example
ghetto here could create a massive Army
of cursed spirits to control UTA could
copy endless techniques of other
sorceress but Gojo doesn't even need the
help of a single cursed Spirit or anyone
else because Gojo could eliminate all
his competition in the jiujitsu world
without even trying now you'll remember
that in Gojo's past the star plasma
vessel incident was a massive turning
point for him both him and GTO together
were an Unstoppable team of special
great Sorcerers with the sole mission of
exercising curses for Jud so high that
was until they of course finally had to
go up against a true monster toi
fushiguro AKA 's father and even though
Gojo's six eyes technique gives him
essentially Limitless control over
cursed energy toji very nearly kills him
and GLE now thankfully Gojo just in time
unlocked his ultimate technique Hollow
purple and managed to kill his future
star pupil's D and at that point
originally like Gojo ghetto thought that
sorceress existed to protect non
Sorcerers or regular humans but after
this event ghetto slowly came to believe
that humans were actually in Furia
taking to calling the monkeys and
working toward or its sorcerer Supremacy
this is of course which led to the judu
kaisen that we know and love or at least
the judu kaisen zero that we know and
love with the two former besties Gojo
and GTO having to fight against one
another as Gojo upheld the values of JSU
high and sorceress protecting humans
while ghetto started working towards
eradicating all humans which is where
things get interesting for our video
here because what if things had gone
differently what if Gojo as a result of
this event the most powerful Sorcerer of
this generation
also had become evil and there are
actually a few ways that this could
possibly shake out four to be exact so
let's look at how juk kaisen would have
played out completely differently if its
greatest and strongest hero had become
its most terrifying villain starting
with scenario number one Gojo turns evil
and GTO actually stays good okay so in
this very first scenario we have a
complete rooll reversal in this one it's
not g Who cracks based on what the two
experienced at at the hands of toi
instead it's Gojo who breaks in fact
let's change it right there this time
instead of toi defeating them both and
then getting crushed by Hollow purple on
his way out he defeats Gojo and is
ultimately defeated by GTO in the tombs
of the star Corridor he does still
manage to kill riko but this time it is
actually GTO who kills toi instead of
Gojo now this ends up resulting in a
huge blow to Gojo's Eagle but a victory
one for G and as we know at this point
Gojo's eagle is about the size of a
whole planet so seeing ghetto succeed
where he ultimately failed would be
really hard for him to deal with as we
know he has never actually lost before
this so Gojo has a real mental breakdown
as a result deciding to break with Jud
so high instead of GLE who stays with
the school nonetheless though I still
don't see Gojo developing the exact same
kind of disgust with regular humans that
GLE us here in fact he does love romcoms
way too much for that kind of thing
however I could very much see him him
breaking with due to high school and
going solo to do his very own thing
instead he is already too powerful to
listen to the higher-ups anyways but
instead of leaving like Yuki did to ride
around on a Cool Motorcycle and talk to
impressionable young men Gojo would be
flexing his powers without any limits as
a result the Jutsu hups would start
receiving concerning reports of cursed
energy output all over Japan however
whenever their sorceress would arrive on
the scene they wouldn't find satu goo
and they wouldn't find any curse Spirits
either just their blooded remains and
buildings completely reduced to Rubble
basically what I'm seeing here is that
when Gojo would go Rogue I think he
would be destroying cursed Spirits with
very little regard for collateral damage
and causing tons of damage with his
insane Powers even though he wouldn't be
Harding melice towards Humanity in
general he would most likely though
Target humans that he deems evil such as
the star religious group specifically
and in this scenario ghetto would have
to be the one to try and stop Gojo now
in case you don't know there are
actually a ton of really cool fan
drawings online where we see what it
would look like if kinjaku actually took
over Gojo's body instead of GTO but that
actually doesn't make sense if you
really think about it you see Kaku would
probably love to have Gojo's curse
technique but at the same time it
actually wouldn't be necessary for his
plan in case you forgot he actually
needs gto's curse technique specifically
because the maximum Uzumaki ability is
what allows him to take maho's Idol
Transfiguration to then break Tang's
barrier during the culling games yes juk
kaisen does get a little bit confusing
sometimes and so since Kaku still needs
gto's technique specifically I still
think that the story would play out with
evil Gojo in this case defeating good
boy GTO with gto's body then being taken
over by kinjaku and this time since Gojo
isn't working for jiuai he doesn't get
sealed away in the prison realm instead
he just gets to show up and wreak
absolute havoc in the calling games
which would be great for for kaku's goal
since the culling game specifically need
to release a ton of cursed energy for
kaku's ritual to work now in this
timeline Gojo becomes the alltime
culling game MVP racking up more points
than anyone and taking out ancient
Sorcerers left and right but of course
we can't just leave it at that because I
still want to know what might happen if
Kaku in fact did take over Gojo's body
and so here is our scenario number two
GTO stays good and Gojo becomes kaku's
body instead oh and well first I guess
we've got to figure out how Gojo
actually dies so that kenju is able to
take over his body in the first place
and since the only person or curse
around who's actually able to remotely
be a match for Gojo is sukuna kenju is
going to have to get the king of curses
on his side luckily enough kaku's son
happens to be a perfect vessel for
sakuna now in this timeline instead of
abandoning the body of kadori Kaku
raises Yuji to be evil together they
start collecting sua's fingers on the DL
with kenju feeding his son the worst
snacks of all time to unleash zuna's
Powers so that his son can finally
eliminate Gojo now Gojo would be
wandering Japan teleporting here and
there eliminating curses when suddenly
coote and her beloved forearmed 20
fingere eating son would suddenly show
up to give him the fight of his life
suddenly Gojo despite his Limitless
curse technique would be pinned to the
ground because kad's reverse curse
technique would use the power of gravity
to pin him to the ground long enough for
sakuna to slice and dice him up with the
malevolent Shrine now again in this
timeline GTO would still be good so no
one's really coming to Gojo's rescue
here kenju is able to catch the evil
Gojo off guard and through a tag team
operation with Kaku and sakuna they
eliminate the world's strongest sorcerer
at this point right here but barely
because even these two need all their
power to even actually hit goo but now
with him out of the way there's no need
to bother with the prism realm and
nothing is able to get in the way of
kaku's evil plan so he just goes defeats
GTO takes over his body too and then the
culling game just happens without a
hitch however now it is time to get to
the real juicy stuff because this time
instead of the rolls being reversed with
ghetto staying good and Gojo being the
evil one ghetto stays evil just like in
the actual story but this time Gojo is
joining him in villain land and let's
just say it's not really looking that
great for the rest of the world which
brings us to scenario number three which
is that after the star plasma vessel
incident it's not just G who decides to
defect from Jud so high instead Gojo
also becomes angry at how things are run
and becomes evil right along with G and
really with both Gojo and GTO leaving
there is now no one left to vouch for
Utah you might remember that originally
the higher UPS of the judu society
actually wanted UTA killed because his
Cur Spirit Raa is so insanely powerful
and it's very possible that this is
actually how things would play out but
more likely if Gojo and GTO both exist
as threats to the established order they
might very well ditch the execution and
try to recruit Utah in order to use his
special great status to somehow defend
against Gojo and ghetto plans UT and his
classmates would be hard at work on
their studies when suddenly an army of
cursed Spirits would descend upon pju
High School Panda Toge and Maki would
put up a courageous fight beating down
Untold numbers of curses and when it
seemed like the onslaught was finally
dying down they'd look behind them and
see them the BFFs Gojo and ghetto ready
to take out judu high now that the
welcoming party was over now of course
UTA and R would fight to their hardest
however just GTO alone was enough to
almost take UTA out so the two of them
together would absolutely wreck the hero
of jutu kaisen zero along with just
about everybody else now in this
scenario of course kaku's role in the
story would also have to be quite
different since he'd be unlikely to take
over either GTO or Gojo's body here much
more likely Kaku would use his abilities
as a master manipulator to join with
them while actually kind of using them
for his own purposes just like he did
with the disaster curses either way
really an evil team up between goo and
ghetto is probably going to to end up
with sorceress coming out of their
secrecy they'd start pulling away young
Sorcerers from their connection to the
established judu society and likely user
in an era of judu Supremacy over regular
humans or I guess monkeys as a ghetto
would call them however even if he went
evil I just can't see Gojo getting fully
on board with gto's philosophy of hating
all humans which does lead us to our
fourth scenario and probably the most
interesting out of all because in
scenario number four G and ghetto both
become evil but instead of partnering up
with one another they still go against
each other and walk their own villainous
path now this would of course introduce
a multitude of different factions that
make the conflict of jutu kaisen a lot
more interesting than it actually
already is in the original story because
while ghetto still turns evil due to his
hatred of humans Gojo is going to turn
evil just because he lets his immense
power get to his head after all even
though Satur Gojo is by far the world's
strongest sorcerer he is still very much
used as a pawn by the judu society and
so instead of listening to the old
traditional rules he would just do his
own thing go his own way and really
cause a huge fracture in the entire jitu
society and so just like in the actual
story where he spends a lot of time
using his power and influence to prevent
the hups from killing young Sorcerers
with potential like UTA and Yuji he
would actually recruit them to his own
site as powerful assets and so surely
other sorcerers who feel Outcast by the
major families would join him too such
as Maki Zayn who is basically treated
terribly by her own family as well at
the same time other sorcerers who are
part of the big families would stay at
their side so this would lead to an
allout war between the Elders of Clans
like the Zay Clan and the camo Clan and
the young Sorcerers who ended up siding
with Gojo sadly Ponda would also remain
on the side of the Old Guard since the
principal of Jutsu High created him
however very much unlike G who still
wants to just Destroy All Humans Gojo
would still want to protect Humanity but
his Newfound vanity and overconfidence
would mean that he'd no longer do it
from the Shadows instead he would then
shed the secrecy of judu high and the
judu society and let it be known far and
wide that Sorcerers were responsible for
protecting Humanity from the terrible
danger of curses he may even take a
queue from Yuki and aim to teach normal
humans how to control cursed energy to
prevent the birth of powerful curses
that start accumulating from the
negative energy released by Regular
People in fact Yuki would very likely be
a powerful Ally to Gojo since she left
on her own to try to rid the world of
the curses free of the restrictions of
the judu society anyways in fact this
was one of the suggestions that she gave
to GTO for how to rid the world of
curses which accidentally then led him
to the conclusion that killing all non
Sorcerers would be the most effective
way of eliminating curses and since that
is still gto's goal that means that he
still be at ODS against Gojo whenever it
comes to battle for the fate of the Jud
Su kaisen world and in the meantime
kenju is still lurking in the shadows
and in all likelihood unable to gather
Gojo or gto's bodies he would probably
still try to Ally with all of the
disaster curses which would basically
lead to an allout war on different sides
for the fate of the entire judu Society
on the one side we have suguro and his
followers such as nanaka and mimiko in
addition to the followers who could use
cursed energy he also have all of the
curses that he was able to gather using
his curse technique leading to an entire
Army of curse spirits on his side
against him on the other side would be
Gojo's group of young Sorcerers
including Yuki and Utah giving them
three special grades on that end also
throwing into the ring would be kinjaku
in cador's body and the disaster curses
who wish to take advantage of the entire
conflict to Massacre as many Sorcerers
and humans as possible and then pave the
way for curses to take over the world
kenju himself would also be taking
advantage of the chaos trying to
eliminate Tan's barrier and he'd even
possibly try to start the culling games
anyway and use the fighting from this
war to activate his ritual and as the
fourth party in this war we would have
master tengen and the Elders of the
three big judu families including many
of the Gojo family who wouldn't
appreciate satu doing his own thing this
entire War would be insanely bloody
leaving huge casualties on every side
but there's only one way that it would
ultimately shake out I think and so once
the dust settled standing over what was
once judu High Gojo's six eyes would
look out over the Carnage principal Yaga
and his puppet Army would litter the
landscape Joo and the other disaster
curses would sit in Cinders and even
ghetto and kenju would be dead and gone
because with Gojo site having three
special grade Sorcerers totally
eclipsing regular lower ranked Sorcerers
Gojo would ultimately win this war and
would reshape the judu world in his own
beautiful blue-eyed image now to be fair
of course if Kaku was actually able to
revive sukuna as well things might play
out very differently but as it is Gojo
is the world's strongest Sorcerer And
there's not a lot that can stop him
after all thanks to his insane power
practically nothing can even touch him
and it really begs the question is he
just holding back in all of his battles
so far in the story and what would
happen if he really let his full
strength fly and the best example for
this is probably the Shibuya incident
because what if he had used his full
strength against the disaster curses
instead of getting trapped in the prison
realm well you can find out all about
that in this video right here thanks for
watching and I will see you in the next
one